you ever hear the expression
what comes up must come down um yes
there's even a song it used to be a
commercial
what goes up must come
down so
i remembered hearing that as a kid and i
said what
what you telling me nothing will can
ever leave earth
like what right so then i remember like
researching middle school is when i
sort of came of age in all of this and
then you realize okay um we
went to the moon okay the
and and there's now of course the
astronauts came back
right but they didn't just fall back
just when that people were just tossed
up and then oh we're
falling back now one giant leap to get
home
so there's like golf carts or rovers on
the moon
they're not coming back right there's
the base of the lam
you know the lunar excursion module the
upper part went up to dock
with the but the water so there are
things that have been
sent into space that are never coming
back
right so where does this saying come
from
well it's a pre-space era
saying all right so you toss something
and gravity is pulling downward on it so
here's what happens
you it leaves your hand with a certain
speed i don't care what the speed is
okay but it's a certain speed and
gravity is pulling down on it
if you want to do it in in english units
32 feet
per second for every second
it's in motion okay so
if i throw it up at let's say 96 miles
an hour
a good fastball okay 96 miles per hour
after one second it's no longer going 96
miles per hour
because the acceleration of gravity
is acting opposite that speed
subtracting away its velocity
so it started out in 96 after one second
how fast is it going
um 32 feet per second
minus 96. you taking that away from 96.
right so now how fast is it going i
don't know i don't know what it is after
one second
96 minus 32 dude oh oh okay because well
wait a minute yes
no you said it's 96 miles per hour
oh embarrassing oh yeah that's so that's
a different chuck calling me out
okay let's let's see i throw here's how
i get out of that real
quick i meant 96 feet per second
oh okay there you go
that's what i meant all along oh okay
okay all right
so i throw it 96 feet per second after
one second how fast is it going
so and now it's uh uh 96 minus 32.
64. okay all right that's after one
second after two seconds how fast is it
going upwards
a half of that so it's another 32 minus
off of that
so now it's 32 right good that's after
two seconds going 32
after one more second how fast is it
going well it just stopped
it stops stops it stops okay after
another second how fast is it going
now it's accelerated back to that 32
feet so now it's coming down 32 feet
per second right okay after second
second
it's 64 and then back to 96 when you
grab it
okay so that entire path holding air
resistance aside for a moment
is perfectly symmetric right okay
and so this is gravity always pointing
downward
of course yeah on the way up it's
subtracting from your speed so we say
deceleration but it's really a negative
acceleration right it's subtracting from
your speed it goes through
zero and now it's adding to your speed
coming back down
sweet all right yeah so that's gravity
doing its thing
cool so i think to myself um suppose i
threw it faster
right it would go higher before it came
back
okay let me throw it at 200 feet per
second a thousand feet per second
a million feet per second whatever pick
a number
there's got to be some point
where it is there a point where it never
comes back
right but you might say well it can
always subtract from it so yeah it's
always going to come back
isn't it well that's what it seemed like
because
based on the example i just gave that's
what it seemed like but wait
but wait as the thing gets higher
it gets farther away from earth
and so earth's force of gravity on it
begins to drop
uh-oh so no longer is it pulling at 32
feet per second down
oh so as it keeps getting higher
earth is still pulling on it but by less
and less
when you explore the consequences of
this there's a speed that you can launch
from earth
where your object gets to infinity
before the earth stops its motion
completely
that is a specific speed from the
surface of every object there is
it is the velocity of escape yeah
you know what we call it the old escape
velocity it's
called the escape velocity that's the
official
in my field we tell it like it is okay
and so
earth has an escape velocity so wait a
minute so that
and that's the same for every whatever
the gravity is
so every gravity every gravity
corresponding corresponding escape
velocity escape
so for earth the escape velocity is
seven
miles per second seven miles per second
so if you could toss something up
at seven miles per second i am signing
with the yankees
immediately earth will slow it down to
zero
right when it gets to infinity
right that's the escape philosophy
that's the escape velocity so
right when it slows down it's already
it's
inside of the it's at infinity right
it's at infinity
okay so now you might say well that's
weird how can you be at infinity well so
here's how that goes all right excellent
if you threw it at eight
miles per second aha
eight miles per second when it gets to
infinity it's still going
okay all right okay it would have eaten
seven of those miles per second by the
time it's at infinity
and by at infinity it's still going
right still moving
okay so you can have greater than the
escape velocity and that means you've
got a place to go even when you've
gotten to infinity
okay so that's a skateboard so escape
philosophy
for the moon is much less for mars it's
a little less than earth on the sun is
much higher
yeah i was going to say um wait what's
the escape velocity
for a black hole aha
there is no escape
it's like that scene in uh chas
commentaries movie
a bronx tale where they shut the door on
the motorcycle gang
after they asked them to kindly leave
the establishment
gentlemen we would appreciate it if you
would leave
and the guys they look at the young
they're all
in suits all the what supposed mobsters
and the motorcycle gang throws a glass
against the
bar and laughs at them like yeah you're
gonna make us leave and then all of a
sudden one of the guys goes over
and locks the door and he looks at the
motorcycle gang and he says
now you just can't leave that's the
black hole
okay that's the gangster black hole
that's against the black hole
now that we had a total tangent off of
the fact that if you're in a black hole
you're not getting out you're not
getting out
because the escape velocity is basically
what
um what's the fastest thing there is
that's the speed of light
right therefore so the black's got to be
faster than that
right yeah so so black hole is has such
a high
gravity at that zone that not even light
can escape
so the escape velocity is the speed of
light
right so the escape fly shows up in all
kinds of ways and places so this whole
thing what goes up must come down
it's yeah if you're just ordinary but if
you're superman no
and we live in the era of superheroes
and space programs and everything
so it's time we retired that statement
right pretty sure
that's what we should do or we could
change it to what goes up at 6.9 miles
per hour or less
must come down
okay no no so it's what goes up at what
goes up at 6.9 miles per second
per second sorry must come down must
come down right exactly
exactly and just to put some icing on
this cake for the astronauts
who went you can go into orbit but
you're still attached to earth
you want to go to the moon you have to
achieve escape velocity otherwise you
will not make it to the moon and you'll
fall back
right okay just like our the ball that
you tossed or this
this exercise that we conducted so
that's why there's a secondary booster
it's called a translunar injection
which sounds like some medicine you
don't want but there you are in orbit
going about five miles per second but
you gotta hit seven miles per second so
you wait until it's just right
and the geometry is just right then you
fire
right in line with the direction you are
headed right that gets
you up to near seven miles per second
and that'll get you to the moon
actually you don't need to get earth you
don't need to get to the moon
you just have to get to the spot where
moon's gravity is stronger than earth
there's gravity wow you just have to get
just to that spot
and then you fall towards the moon all
right so wait a minute
so could that is that how they did
when they did the flyby did they just
allow the moon's gravity to take
flybuys they're not done that way but if
you want to land that's how you do it
okay if you want to land you just need
enough fuel to get to that point
at that point and then you then you just
get there crosses over the hill and you
just
and now you're just going downhill
that's going downhill
oh my god that's that's pretty brilliant
that these people figured this out
yeah it's called science
are you just discovering this now my god
people do this stuff
we've got to do more with this science
stuff neil
we definitely have to do more with the
science fiction that's how we get to
mars even
we don't have we don't pack fuel to get
to mars we pack fuel
to get to the point where mars gravity
takes over then we fall towards mars
sweet because that's less fuel you don't
want to take more fuel than you have to
exactly so you're never really flying to
mars you're flying
at mars waiting for mars to come and
grab you
to come to mars cool you're not waiting
you're you're this is very calculated
right
excuse me act like will it will they
take us willing
[Laughter]
wouldn't that be funny if that's how you
had to do it like you're getting
oh my god i hope if you just barely miss
it then you just sling yourself back to
earth and yeah
there you go that's so cool man that's
and one last thing just an interesting
thought experiment
again neglecting air resistance here if
you take a high-powered rifle
and shoot it straight up high power
rifles go thousand
miles i mean they're they go faster than
sound okay
shoot it straight up it'll go all the
way up okay
right and every second it loses 32 feet
per second speed
it reaches zero and then it comes back
and every second it gains 32
feet and it'll fall right back down the
nozzle of your gun
at the same speed that it left
okay uh thereby killing you and you
so there you go knighting the magazine
if you're a yahoo the lesson here is
don't fire your guns in the air okay
not straight up no air resistance would
slow down the bullet on the way down
okay so uh anyhow check oh by the way
escape velocity neglects air resistance
so right
so you'd have to compensate for the air
resistance if you were doing
doing it because the air eats up some of
your energy exactly anyway that's it
chuck that's
what goes up will only sometimes must
come down
there you go there you have it tell me
how we're going to reword it now
it's what goes up must come down
as long as it's going less than 6.9
miles per second
okay there you have that catchy phrase
just invented
you heard it here on star talk all right
we gotta run
all right all right chuck always good to
have you always a pleasure
be able to grasp tyson here keep looking
up
[Music]
you